all right now according to a release
from the State Department that would be
Mike Pompeo State Department the three
freed hostages have issued a statement
writing quote we would like to express
our deep appreciation to the United
States government to President Trump to
secretary Pompeo and the people of the
United States for bringing us home we
thank God and all our families and
friends who prayed for us and for our
return god bless america
the greatest nation in the world can't
wait for them to land joining us now
with reaction to all the big
developments today former deputy
assistant to the president Fox News
national security strategist dr.
Sebastian Walker retired CIA
intelligence officer we welcome him to
the Fox family of course he's been on a
lot our friend Daniel Hoffman dr. Gorka
let me start with you these hostages are
freed it took military presence it took
the president taunting Kim jong-un it
took sanctions but it worked and I don't
believe the president brought in 150
billion dollars in cash and other
currencies and cargo planes to make this
happen is it a great night to be an
American Sean this is stunning the
President and Secretary Pompeo with this
one act have done more for America than
Obama and his whole cabinet did in eight
years
no more appeasement no more middle of
the night
pallets of currency being shipped to our
enemies what what did we pay for these
three Americans to come home Sean
nothing we dealt with a dictator as you
should deal with all dictators no
appeasement walk softly and carry a very
big stick or an aircraft carrier battle
group that's how you get things done it
is you know the new day for America and
this is a message for all dictatorships
and this is the model for how we deal
with Iran we've shown Iran no more
appeasement and I'm telling the
president and everybody in his in his
circle we use the Pyongyang model that
Pompeo has effectively deployed to deal
with regimes like Iran Shawn you know
about Noah Munck Pompeyo
long time I'm very proud of what he did
I'm very proud of what the president did
here Daniel Hoffman I think you rightly
have been telling people manager
expectations we I know we're talking
about something that is massive and that
would be the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula so important but also
we never thought a year ago that Kim
jong-un would cross the DMZ into the
arms of the president of South Korea
we never thought he would agree to have
such talks and we would no longer see
missiles flying over Japan Guam
threatened or talks about firing
missiles that could reach New York and
Boston yes we should manage our
expectations trust and verify peace
through strength but it is certainly far
more Hope than we have had in a long
time right and this was a very tangible
and positive result of this
administration's foreign policy Shawn
and while we celebrate this diplomatic
and humanitarian success we need to
remember as well that there are
reportedly about 150 to 200 thousand
political prisoners in North Korea this
is like akin to the Soviet gulag and
while our three former soon-to-be former
former hostages you know after they
receive the medical care I'm sure
they'll need I think they'll be very
very valuable sources of information on
these North Korean prison labor camps
and the awful horrendous conditions to
which innocent people are subjected and
it's important for us to call out North
Korea on their horrific behavior towards
towards their own population and towards
our citizens as well you know I want to
go
Israel tonight earlier today a couple
hours ago multiple missiles fired by
around from Syria no Israeli has been
hurt I talked to high-level government
sources Colonel North has his sources in
the IDF thank God but Israel has struck
back tonight from my intelligence
sources they went directly to where
those missiles were fired this of course
was in retaliation to Israel effectively
taking out a lot of these sites that
they have been using in Syria dr. Gorka
yes so the the wonderful thing about the
nation of Israel
is that they have capabilities in the
region that are unmatched and when they
feel a threaten when they they have the
requisite intelligence they take action
the the massive change for Israel now is
that now they have us to stand with them
shoulder to shoulder as the vice
president said on the anniversary of the
69th year of the founding of the State
of Israel I was in the room of the vice
president says we stand with Israel
Israel's enemies are our enemies and in
a week look what's over this weekend
look what's gonna happen Daniel Hoffman
Jerusalem now the capital so many people
promised it happened president Trump
another promise kept extraordinary sea
change Shawn absolutely but I think this
is a precursor for more kinetic action
in Syria Iran is using that territory
against Israel and I think I fear that
it may only get worse it may and I don't
know if I take on the Israeli Defense
Forces nor do I think you take on
Israel's best ally the United States
thank you both